-Thank you very much.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
And that's the Roots
right over there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
as I mentioned earlier,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg's passing
dominated the news this weekend.
Even President Trump
seemed genuinely saddened
when he heard about it.
Actually you thought
we were finally seeing
a more empathetic Trump
until he addressed
the open Supreme Court seat
at his rally 24 hours later.
-So, I have to make a decision
to fill the seat, as we say.
We should have a new campaign.
Let's make a T-shirt --
"Fill the Seat," okay?
[ Crowd chanting ]
That's a -- That's a good idea.
Fill the seat.
-Wow.
Man, when you see that,
it's hard to believe Trump
hasn't been asked
to give the eulogy.
[ Laughter ]
Trump could be somber for about
15 seconds, then he's like,
"You think they'll have
Bagel Bites at the reception?"
[ Laughter ]
What is he doing?
Why do all of his rallies --
Why do they all have chants?
He's the President,
not the host of an infomercial.
Fry that chicken!
[ Laughter ]
You don't want a room of people
chanting during a pandemic.
Seriously, at that point, even
the coronavirus puts on his coat
and was like, "I don't want to
be part of this, okay?
Good day to you."
But if you thought
Trump was joking,
look at what popped up on
his website over the weekend.
Yeah, the Trump campaign
is now selling
"fill that seat" T-shirts.
Seriously, someone just passed
away and he's leading chants
and selling T-shirts
like they just clinched
the American League East.
When people said
it was in bad taste,
Trump was like, "Good call.
Let's also print out some
college shirts, class it up."
Here's some advice -- If you're
wondering how to deal with
a job opening after someone dies
and you find yourself
on a custom T-shirt website,
you made a wrong turn.
[ Laughter ]
Even long-haul drivers
with truck nuts were like,
"That's just
crude and unnecessary."
[ Laughter ]
But it's true. Trump is hoping
to fill the seat soon
and he even offered some details
on who he's thinking about
filling it with.
-I will be putting forth
a nominee next week.
It will be a woman.
-Trump said that
like he was announcing
the gender of
the next royal baby.
[ Laughter ]
"Hear ye, hear ye,
it will be a woman."
[ Laughter ]
This is actually good news
because usually when you hear
"Trump, judge," and "woman"
in the same sentence,
it's because he's
being sued again.
[ Laughter ]
And this morning
on "Fox & Friends,"
Trump was asked if he knew which
day he'd announce the nominee.
Watch this.
"That's right.
We want to be very respectful.
I even asked Kid Rock to record
an acoustic version
of 'Bawitdaba' to be played
during the funeral."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they're trying
to be respectful.
That's why for the next hour
Trump's knocking 20% off
all "fill that seat"
merchandise, so act now!
[ Laughter ]
Trump is being very respectful,
but when asked about
Justice Ginsburg's dying wish
for the next president
to choose her successor,
here's what he had to say.
Well, that was
an interesting way
of paying respects, wasn't it?
Over the weekend,
Republican senators like
Ted Cruz, Mitch McConnell,
and Lindsey Graham
said they plan to move forward
with a vote on Trump's nominee.
However, that contradicts
what they said back in 2016
when President Obama
nominated Merrick Garland
close to an election.
Listen to this.
-There is a long tradition
that you don't do this
in an election year.
-The Senate will appropriately
revisit the matter
when it considers the
qualifications of the nominee
the next President nominates.
-I want you to use
my words against me.
If there's a Republican
President in 2016
and a vacancy occurs in
the last year of the first term,
you can say Lindsey Graham said
"Let's let the next president,
whoever it might be,
make that nomination."
-Sure, the Olympics
were canceled this year,
but at least we have
the Republicans to show off
some truly spectacular
backflips.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans are just constantly
changing the rules as they go.
It's like playing a board game
with a toddler.
It's like, "I rolled a two
and I'm wearing blue, so I win."
[ Laughter ]
And now, because he completely
changed his position,
people are calling
Mitch McConnell spineless.
Can we see Mitch McConnell?
[ Laughter ]
Spineless? Based on that,
I'm pretty sure he's boneless.
[ Laughter ]
We're already in the middle of
a global pandemic,
racial unrest,
and a cratering economy.
Now there's going to be a fight
over an open Supreme Court seat.
At this rate, next week's debate
will be about how to handle
the current alien invasion.
[ Laughter ]
2020 really is insane.
To put things in perspective,
the biggest news of 2019
was baby Yoda.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously,
this election already felt
like a tense Thanksgiving
dinner.
Now it's like your uncle just
rolled in straight from rehab.
[ Laughter ]
Trump says he'll announce
his Supreme Court pick
Friday or Saturday.
Before he does that, though,
he's been calling up
all the finalists to let them
know they didn't get the job.
Check out this leaked audio.
-Ted, I can't have someone
on the Supreme Court
with a beard like yours.
You look like a college freshman
who's experimenting with
his look over winter break,
but even a college freshman
knows to shave it off
when the selfie
doesn't get enough likes.
Son, I love you,
but we can't have someone
on the Supreme Court
who has the same energy
as a guy who offers you cocaine
in the bathroom of
a Buffalo Wild Wings.
I just think those robes would
be too heavy on you, Jared.
Put them on and you'll crumble
to the floor
like the Witch
from "Wizard of Oz."
MyPillow guy, you are maybe
the smartest person who has ever
lived, besides me.
And I think that you could have
made a wonderful judge,
presiding over some wonderful
pillow-based cases,
but unfortunately you're --
how should I put this? --
a borderline insane man.
Hey, me, it's me calling.
Hello. I love what you do.
Big fan. Likewise.
I think you're the most
qualified person on Earth
to be on the Supreme Court.
Wow, what an honor to be
nominated by you, me.
[ Laughter ]
-And finally, the most important
thing Americans can do is vote,
and it looks like we're
getting some help from somewhere
you wouldn't expect. Watch this.
-Foot Locker is turning
thousands of their stores
into voter-registration sites
just six weeks
before the election.
-It's perfect
'cause when a fight breaks out,
there will be 40 people dressed
like referees to handle it.